عوده الان الى التطور الاحدث في مسلسل او
بالاحرى ماساه طالبي اللجوء نتحدث عن
انتشال جثث عشره من طالبي لجوء اثراء غرقي
مركبه قباله سواحل الشرق تونس ماذا حدث
تقول السلطات التونسيه انهم انطلقوا من
سواحل محافظه صفاقس على متن يقارب خشبي من
الحجم الكبير وكانوا في اتجاه السواحل
الاوروبيه ليس الحدث هو الاول فقد ارتفعت
وتيره محاولات عبور البحر الابيض المتوسط
من قبل الطالبي لجوء متجهين نحو السواحل
الايطاليه بشكل لافت في الفتره الاخيره مع
تحسن احوال الطقس
تسجل تونس التي تبعد بعض سواحلها اقل من
150 كيلومترا عن جزيره لمبيدوسا الايطاليه
محاولات متكرره من طالبي لجوء ينحدر
معظمهم من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء وقد
لقي اربعه طالبي لجوء من افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء حتفهم وفقد 23 في حديثي غرق
الجمعه والسبت قباله سواحل تونس في حين تم
انقاذ 53 اخرين
في السادس والعشرين من مارس ان انتشلت جثث
تسعه وعشرين طالبه لجوء من افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء اثراء غرق ثلاثه قوارب قباله
سواحل تونس وتم انقاذه 11 شخصا
يقول الحرس الوطني التونسيين اكثر من 14
الف طالب لجوء معظمهم من افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء تم اعتراضهم او انقاذهم في الاشهر
الثلاثه الاولى من العام الحالي وذلك
اثناء محاولتهم العبور الى اوروبا اي خمسه
اضعاف الارقام المسجله في الفتره نفسها من
العام الماضي القلق يزداد في روما
الحكومه الايطاليه اعلنت بالامس حاله
طوارئ لمده سته اشهر وذلك
لمواجهه ازمه موجات طالبي اللجوء المتدفقه
بزياد على حدودها خلال الفتره الاخيره
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا امس قالت
ان اوروبا ربما تواجه خطر وصول موجه ضخمه
من المهاجرين الى شواطئها من شمال افريقيا
عدد المهاجرين الوافدين الى ايطاليا ارتفع
بشكل حاد في الاشهر الاخيره مقارنه
بالفتره ذاتها من العام الماضي على الرغم
من جهود الحكومه الائتلافيه اليمينيه
لتضييق الخناق على طالبي اللجوء